je vous présente aujourd'hui les 9
meilleurs smartphones pliant en partance
du plus mauvais ou de celui qui m'a le
moins plus ou du moins réussies en
allant jusqu'aux meilleur mon coup de
coeur le format qui m'aura le plus plu
alors ici l'idée je vous présentais des
smartphones qui se plie avec des écrans
flexibles et des écrans qui s'enroulent
du pliable de l'an roulable il ya neuf
formats différents qui sont extrêmement
intéressante et surtout conso pour dire
ce que vous en pensez lequel vous
préférez bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire on y va
[Musique]
allez on commence par le tout premier
c'est le neuvième neuvième position
c'est celui qui fait mal - plus et le
royaume le flex paille alors c'est
intéressant parce que souvenez vous je
vous emmène dans le passé royal a été la
première marque à lancer un smartphone
pliane en tout cas l'annoncé alors
clairement n'est pas un smartphone
destiné le vendus pour le grand public
un smartphone à faire de la masse du
volume non c'était plus pour montrer
l'innovation la technologie l'écran
qu'ils se pliaient tel flex paille or le
flex paille j'ai pris en main pour lui
montrer lorsque j'étais au csa vegas me
semble-t-il c'était il ya deux ans et là
on peut voir un sorti un fake ce pack 2
on le voit sur leur site alors c'est un
peu comme l'idée du flex paille numéro 1
à savoir qu'en fait votre smartphone il
se prend il se referme et l'écran est
totalement à l'extérieur alors c'est
assez marrant vers des usages rigolo
mais tout le dos du smartphone et bien
vous n'avez rien donc lorsqu'il est
ouvert vous avez un côté vous n'avez
absolument rien et c'est toujours le
même côté de l'écran qui est affichée
qui n'est pas protégé ça qui peut être
un petit peu embêtant parce que ça
smartphones que pont coup on ne peut
absolument pas venir protéger c'est un
coup de com s'est mise en avant des
technologies et du savoir faire ici de
rougeole mais pas plus pas lieu il est
rigolo mais ils cassent pas 4 ils
cassent pas quatre pattes à un canard ne
casse pas trois pattes à un canard
d'ailleurs je me combien de pattes à un
canard leonardo a priori 8ème position
se retrouve avec un smartphone de
motorola c'est le razer alors lowrider
il vient ressusciter le razer qui était
là il ya très longtemps et là on a un
smartphone qui se plie alors le format
je trouve marrant regardé comme on le
voit ici il est assez rigolo on voit
effectivement qu'on a un écran recentre
avec une encoche en haut il vient se
plier le form factor et bien parce qu'il
dira ce compact et donc ça c'est rigolo
on a un petit écran extérieur et une
caméra c'est bien c'est intéressant mais
vu la performance qu'on a à l'intérieur
et vu le prix on est quasiment à 1600
euros on n'y est pas alors il se
pourrait qu'on ait un autre smartphone
au trésor qui arrivent plus performant
au plus beau on verra on suivra ça donc
ce format je trouve 1 parce qu'on gagne
de la place on vient réduire donc
motorola a bien bossé mais le reste de
la fiche technique suffit pas
l'innovation est là mais bon voilà donc
c'est pas mal mais peut mieux faire on
continuait comme smartphone de voir où
et c'est le myhtique cesse myhtique
c'est sûr on a déjà vu il ya un petit
moment alors autant je trouve très jolie
l'écran est sympa lorsque vous venez le
plier regarder il est comme ça il se
plie en deux c'est pareil un peu comme
le smartphone de royal comme le flex pas
il est via se replier il est plutôt bien
il se prend bien en main il est
intéressant mais c'est pas le meilleur
form factor par rapport aux smartphones
pliable autant ces jolies autant ça
marche bien mais voilà c'est pas là
dessus que j'avais eu un coup de coeur
et c'est pas vraiment le smartphone que
j'ai venir recommandé huawei a présenté
fin d'année dernière un autre smartphone
pillages mais je le montre dans quelques
instants un peu plus loin dans cette
vidéo on continue avec un smartphone de
samsung c'est le galaxy z folle de 300
excellent smartphone très beau
smartphone je voulais présenter on l'a
testé on l'a découvert on a fait plein
de choses avec il est extrêmement
intéressant le seul truc c'est qu'il est
un peu grand est encore un petit peu
épais donc dans la poche il prend de la
place mais le service qu'il rend est
vraiment bien vous avez un très grand
écran extérieur peut venir utiliser
fermé lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous êtes
encore un plus grand écran et le
bénéfice que vous avez c'est qu'en plus
avait une caméra qui est planqué sous
l'écran alors c'est une 4 mégapixels on
s'énerve pas c'est pas le truc le plus
fou fou mais ça fonctionne et en plus de
ça il est compatible espen nous pouvons
l'utiliser pour de la productivité avec
votre stylet c'est une très très belle
bête un très joli smartphones aussi un
très bon photophone avec beaucoup de
performances à l'intérieur il est
vraiment bien et moi je dirais classé à
la sixième position alors tout en
sachant qu'en plus vous avez d'autres
smartphones pour un peu le même form
factor on va voir le mix fold de chiens
au mythe c'est à dire un grand
smartphone qui vient se plier en deux
avec un grand écran à la vente c'est
vraiment le même form factor il ya
quelques différences bien évidemment bon
les marques travaillent différemment le
blog photo n'est pas le même il ya
quelques finitions qui sont différentes
mais dans l'ensemble c'est la même idée
toujours dans la navy des on a le honor
magic vers le haut nord magic v je vous
ai fait une vidéo pour vous le présenter
c'est un smartphone qui est très sympa
qui vient se plier comme le samsung
galaxy z folle de trois on retrouve le
même form factor un grand écran immersif
ça fonctionnera c'est très très bien
très très joli mais on est dans le même
format que le samsung galaxy z paul ii
iii dont je les laisse dans la même
catégorie on est ici en sixième position
5e position c'est le au pot find and je
voulais présenter ya pas très longtemps
j'ai pu le prendre en main alors je
trouve un peu plus intéressant que le
galaxy z folle de troie parce qu'un peu
plus de 6 légèrement plus compact on a
vraiment un écran carré il est super
agréable en termes de prise en main et
sera un peu moins grand très compact
bref une belle réussite pour l'instant
c'est pas du tout aux smartphones qui
devraient mais en france il restera
uniquement dédié pour la chine mais je
ne doute pas que dans les temps à venir
on verra arriver un smartphone pliable
signé au pot en tout cas on voit qu'on a
un produit fini à destination de la
chine donc j'imagine que dans le reste
du monde ça ne saurait tarder quatrième
position on reste chez au pot c'est le
au pot x 2021 alors là je voulais
présenter l'année dernière début 2021 on
n'est pas sur un smartphone qui se plie
au lait sur un smartphone qui
s'enroulent vous avez votre smartphone
ou touché sur le côté et il va venir
s'ouvrir ça vous fait un plus grand
smartphone pour le coup on a absolument
aucune pliure on ne sent rien sur le
doigt alors ceci étant dit avec le hop
aux fans n on le sent pas énormément
sous le doigt mais là ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est vraiment cool un smartphone qui
s'enroulent qui se déplie c'est
vachement bien alors après y'a pas
d'autres contraintes est ce qu'on a le
risque de mettre de la poussière des
grains de sable à l'intérieur là où ils
sont ou est-ce que les mécanismes
peuvent être maltraités on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas c'est un proto en tout
cas j'ai adoré ce proto et je trouvais
que c'était une des meilleures
propositions qu'on pouvait voir arriver
donc réglé dessus bravo pour troisième
position c'est chez samsung samsung
galaxy flex g flex s on est ici sur des
prototypes on est sur des smartphones
qui ont été montrés mais qui ne sont pas
du tout commercialisé regardez ici vous
avez les deux smartphones ils sont très
choqués parce qu'en fait ils se plient
en trois parties ça regardez ça vous
fait une énorme tas blake c'est vraiment
extrêmement bleus font alors ça c'est
vraiment l'idée de punir amener une
tablette et là c'est un smartphone donc
on le pli en trois dans un sens ou dans
un autre c'est vachement bien leur
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on aura un
smartphone qui sera forcément plus épais
mais les écrans pliables lui permettent
également de faire ça là c'est une démo
de samsung tout ça vraiment extrêmement
de l'oeuf alors pour l'instant ce ne
sont pas des smartphones finis sont pas
des produits qui sont commercialisés
distribués mais sont des formats qui
sont super intéressant donc on verra
s'il arrive dans les temps à venir en
tout cas je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant ça nous emmène à la deuxième
position le deuxième meilleur smartphone
plèbe le meilleur concept 7 et c'est
elle qui le propose avec le fold and
roll alors c'est quoi cette idée et bien
vous avez un smartphone qui se plie tout
simplement et qu'ils ont plus s'enroule
regardez regardez ça c'est complètement
dingue donc votre smartphone il va venir
s'ouvrir et en plus il va venir
s'étendre ici je trouve que le concept
est fou vous avez une glissière vous
avez une charnière regarder la charnière
aller là vous allez venir l'ouvrir tout
simplement et elle pourrait il va venir
s'agrandir l'idée super intéressante
alors pour autant vous voyez que vous
avez votre écran qui à l'extérieur et
non à l'intérieur un peu comme ce qu'on
a chez huawei avec le myhtique cesse un
peu comme ce qu'on a vu également chez
royall avec le flec spike donc ce n'est
pas idéal mais l'idée est là c'est à
dire c'est un smartphone qui va venir
s'agrandir si vous n'avez pas assez bien
pour en avoir plus haut ça vachement
bien c'est super intéressant car c'était
pas le conseil qu'une fois de plus le
plus abouti mais pour autant il est là
il est efficace il est intéressant il
est sexy c'est une innovation ce qui
n'était cl je trouve ça vachement bien
puisque nous emmène à la première
position mon smartphone préféré dans
l'éventail de tous les smartphones
pigalle et bien c'est le samsung galaxy
z flic 3 pourquoi parce que vous
répondez à quasiment tous les problèmes
vous avez un smartphone que vous allez à
grandir vous avez un smartphone vous
venez le rétrécir pour autant vous avez
un format qui est vachement bien il
prend plus de place vous avez un écran
extérieur qui n'est pas seulement un
écran notification mais qui peut servir
ce que vous allez venir faire des photos
bref c'est un format qui est vraiment
bien très intéressant voit
qu'effectivement il est complémentaire
par rapport à d'autres formats mais
celui là je vais beaucoup et je vous ai
présenté ya pas longtemps que souvenez
vous je vous emmener os et ios en été
sur le stand de tester l on a vu le tcl
chicago puis d'un prototype qui ne
sortira jamais mais qui reprenait les
codes de ce smartphone de samsung avec
une pliure qu'on ne sentait quasiment
pas sous le doigt je trouvais ça
vachement bien très belle réussite et de
la même manière vous avez le même form
factor qui a été repris par huawei au
niveau du p 50 pocket un smartphone qui
va venir se plier comme le samsung
galaxy z flip 3 donc on va que ce form
factor car développer samsung plaît
énormément deux acteurs vont vous dire
dessus je trouve ça super intéressant
donc les smartphones pliable se déplie
se déploie regard ça comme ça de plus en
plus bien aura de toutes les formes et
là vous parle de formes connues
aujourd'hui mais ils ont en bonne forme
qu'on ne connaîtra pas et au terme de
forme qu'on ne connaît pas et bien il y
aussi d'autres marques devraient arriver
que des smartphones pliable notamment
google avec un pixel fold qui pourrait
potentiellement arriver va y avoir de
nouvelles copies de nouveaux smartphones
pliable qui vont être présenté de
nouvelles innovations dont trouve ça
extrêmement passionnant ayant plus on le
voit là tout de suite au niveau des
smartphones on a également des
ordinateurs qui se plie vous ai présenté
ya pas longtemps le asus zenbook 17 oled
fold est un ordinateur qui se plie de la
même manière l'année dernière je vous
avais montré le lenovo thinkpad x1 phone
qui est également un ordinateur qui se
plie puis une autre de lier un peu sur
le côté c'est la nubie ahwach donc voyez
ça split tous les côtés je trouve ça
cool on reparlera bien évidemment
d'écran qui se plie au travers de
smartphones de pc de montrer que sais-je
encore parce que je trouve ça
extrêmement passionnant puis c'est
peut-être probablement une vision du
futur pourquoi pas sur du verre hebel
des vêtements avec des écrans comme nous
le montre également royaume soit c'est
intéressant on en reparle bientôt vous
embrasse pour les soigner vous il ya
très bientôt des bisous tiens
[Musique]